عام 2017 فجاه امير عيد مطرب فرقه كايروكي
الجمهور بمظهره واثار التكهنات بعدما خسرت
66 كيلو جراما من وزنه حيث ان البعض اتهمه
بتعاطي المخدرات لكنه ارجع ذلك الى
مضاعفات عمليات جراحيه في 2019
الفنانه احلام لافته الانظار بجمهور بعد
خساره نحو عشرين كيلو جراما من وزنها
وقالت انها فقدت شهيتها اتجاه الطعام
وتتبع نظام غذائيا وانتقدت من يرجع خساره
وزنها الى استخدام برنامج الفوتوشوب
الفنانه المصريه مايكل السابق اختارت
اجراء عمليه تكميم المعده بناء على رغبه
ابنتها وايضا حفاظا على صحتها ولفتت النظر
بخسارتها الوزن خلال ظهورها الاخير في
مسلسل جعفر العمده المطربه الانجليزيه
اداء الخسرت اكثر من خمسه واربعين كيلو
جراما خلال عام 2019 بفضل ممارستها
الرياضه ثلاث مرات يوميا وتقول ان هذا
التحول ساعدها على الصعيد النفسي قبل
الجسدي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات